so last month for my patron only video
we looked
at the beginning of the story of sierra
gawain and the green knight
and so this week we're going to look at
the second part of the story
and go deeper into its analysis so if
you haven't watched the first part of
this video i would say go watch it
before you watch this one or else you
will be a little lost
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so when we left sir gawain in our story
he was
now on christmas day one year after
he had cut off the head of the green
knight and he was now
trying to find a castle and so he prayed
that he could find a place to
to hear the mass on christmas day and
then he sees this castle at a distance
on arriving at the castle he's received
by the lord of the castle and his lady
who is sitting with him
and the cast the lord of course accepts
to let him stay
but also proposes to him a
strange deal the king says that
he is going to go hunting the next day
and at the end of the day he will give
him
the the whatever it is that he's able to
catch
in exchange for whatever it is that sir
gawain is able to catch at the castle
so of course uh cesar gawain accepts
this deal not really knowing what he's
getting into
and the next day when he wakes up the
king has
left and is hunting
and while zergoen is still in his bed
the lady of the castle comes in and
comes to sit next to his bed
of course there she is and she is trying
to seduce him
of course sir gawain is an honorable
knight and so he tries to
to dodge and to get out of the way and
he tries to avoid
refusing her outright but also
you know trying to be polite about it
trying to be very courteous
while also not giving in to the
temptation
we have to understand that he's in a
very difficult situation because
if we remember the story of uh
if we remember the story of joseph in
egypt we know that
to to refuse her outright and to insult
her would be dangerous for his own
reputation because then she
could accuse him to her husband of
course that's not said directly in the
story
but we feel in the story that he's in
danger he has to be careful
and so he's able to dodge the seduction
and the lady finally is able to steal a
kiss from him
and before she leaves his room so when
the lord
of the mansion a right lord of the
castle arrives
the lord gives him a a venison that he
was able to
to get a doe that he was able to hunt
and
sir going goes up to the the knight and
kisses him
one time and so you know there's a bit
of humor there's a there's a bit of like
okay you know
this is very strange no questions asked
uh and so the next day
the same thing happens again the lady
goes into the room and she tries to
seduce him more forcefully
and here go into voids itch he gets
she's able to take two kisses from him
and again
the night the knight comes back with i
think it's a boar this time and
the same exchange two kisses for the
boar's head it happens three times
on the third time the lady is very
insisting
and she asks for gawain to give her some
token of his
love some like love token and gerwayne
is avoiding is avoiding
and finally she wants to offer him
something as a token
of of love and he refuses until
she mentions her girdle she mentions
that she has this
very special girdle a green girdle that
if he wears this girdle
then nothing can harm him
and so so sir gawain
finally gives in and accepts to wear
this girdle
when the king arrives of course
once again the final thing that he
hunted was a fox
and sir gawain offers him the three
kisses that she was able to steal from
him
but he doesn't offer the girdle
that night the so then sir gawain ends
up leaving
leaving the castle and goes out to find
the green knight in order to
you know fulfill his promise of having
the green knight
give a blow at his head so he searches
for the green chapel which is where he
was supposed to meet the green knight
and arrives at a cave which he realizes
is the
green castle
there he is and the green knight finally
does appear
you know telling him that he needs to
get ready to receive his blow
and so sir gawain places himself
you know presents his neck to receive a
blow and
twice the the green knight
feigns the blow you know hits the ground
uh
misses and every time sir going kind of
jumps
back but he accepted to receive one blow
and so he presents his neck again
the second time and then finally the
third time
the green knight hits towards his neck
and
stops and just nicks his neck
very slightly and then going gets up
pulls his sword out and said that's it
you said one blow
you've given your blow this is it i'm
not gonna give in to more
of your attacks and the green knight
starts to laugh
and uh reveals to him that he is in fact
the lord of the castle in disguise and
that the whole thing was a test
that he passed and he said you passed
the test you were able to pass the test
of hospitality
by not giving in to the seduction of my
wife
but because you refused to give me the
girdle
i had to leave my mark on you i had to
leave a little nick on your neck
and so he also reveals that that he was
sent
by uh morgan le fay who is a very
strange character in arthurian legend a
kind of
very strange witch character who is
actually related to king arthur
and uh he's you know he's the the knight
is very jolly and very happy to see that
going that succeeded in this test
and he says why don't you come with us
and have din with us at the castle we i
forgot to mention that this
is happening on new year's day that is
we are really at this
transition between the two years and so
he invites him to come to the castle but
sierra gawain realizes that
he was not completely forthright and he
goes back
to the the king arthur's castle
and doesn't agree to to stay with the
green knight and he is
sad he's sad to realize and he puts the
guarder on his arm as a kind of sign
of his shame and he goes back to the
castle
wearing the garter he tells the story to
king arthur he tells the story all to
all the knights and all the knights
are very happy to hear that he
succeeded that he's still alive that he
wasn't had and didn't get his head
chopped off
chopped off but sergio wayne is not able
to celebrate with them because he
carries this secret
shame and the secret knowledge that he
did not
fully succeed in his quest
and so it's a very strange story it's a
very strange story there's a lot of
elements
now the first thing to point out
is very fascinating just just right to
the side is that there there seems to be
a relationship
with this sir going in the green knight
and also
the story of frodo who brings the ring
to mordor all of it seems to be related
seems
very much seems like token was inspiring
himself from this um
from this this story of the sir gawain
especially since tokyo also
translated made a version of sierra
going
in modern english this idea of
the success but that is mitigated with
failure that there is some failure in
his success
this idea of succeeding in your quest
but
being let's say tainted by
the success and the quest seems to be
related to the story of
tokens lord of the rings so let's go
through the elements
and as we go through the elements we can
kind of understand what is happening
now as i mentioned last time this is
happening during the time of the
transition between
the old and the new it is related also
to the solstice related to the end of
the year and the beginning of the year
and so the challenge the the very
strange challenge that was posed to him
by the green knight
um at least even as it began was a very
strange one because it wasn't the normal
challenge it wasn't a challenge of
two nights fighting saying fight me and
whoever wins
will you know will be will succeed in
the challenge it was it was saying
you chopped my head off you basically
give me a blow
and i will give you another blow next
year and so it's kind of a weird upside
down challenge and it launches
sir going into a kind of strange upside
down world
and the upside down world is really
though this world of the margin
it's the world of the end you can see it
because it's happening during the end of
the year
the the during the during christmas time
which is when the sun is at
at its lowest at the end of the year in
the beginning of the year so there's
this
idea of this transition and basically
sir wayne is going to get his head cut
off
right he cut off the head of the former
cycle he cut the sun off
and now it's his turn to get his head
cut off as he inaugurated
this new cycle you know this is a very
very old old imagery
imagery that is in ancient ancient uh
creation myths of gods getting castrated
or getting their heads cut off or
being dismembered in order to start off
the new world
and so this all of this is related to
that
so when sir gawain arrives in the world
of the stranger
he has to accept hospitality and so now
sir gawain
is himself a foreigner in a foreign land
and when you are a foreigner in a
foreign land things
become are very strange things are not
the same as when you're in your own land
and you see this in scripture you see
this in many stories
and what sir gawain faces is a kind of
upside down world where instead of
him being the knight who let's say
conquers the lady or the knight who
conquers
in terms of hunting you know who goes
out and hunts the prey
who goes out and defeats the dragon who
goes out and defeats the enemy
he is in a world where he is now the
prey
he is being preyed upon by the foreign
woman he's being preyed upon by the
foreign queen
and he has to act like a
he has to act like a prey and he has to
dodge
the attacks he has to dodge the uh the
the
this predator that is trying to get him
and so
here is this kind of upside down world
where usually the man is the one who
courts
the lady the man is the one who's trying
to conquer the lady but in this
situation it is now the lady who's
trying to conquer him
and he has to kind of avoid it and so
this is the and
the the contrast is it's important to
show where as he's a host
in the castle of the foreigner the
foreigner is the one who's going out and
who's hunting and
who is conquering who is gathering the
the the potential of the world and
bringing it back to the castle
whereas gawain is in this weird upside
down world and
upside down is also because you know he
is the stranger in the house of the king
and now he is he is the one receiving
affection from the queen
and so that is also part of this strange
upside-down world and it appears to him
as a test because
and it's very interesting it's very
interesting to understand it that way
especially in terms of the notion of the
honorable knight
to he it is a test of his virtue
that he is virtuous even though he is
not in his own land
it is the ultimate test of virtue that
he is able to remain
to keep his character in
in that upside down world in a world
where he is not accountable
you know in the same way that he would
be accountable in his home he's able to
remain virtuous now this is something
that we experience
all the time if you've traveled if
you've gone to places where no one knows
you
you understand that you're always in a
danger of
behaving in a way that is not the type
of way you would behave at home because
you you
no one knows you you're not accountable
to anybody
right and so and so you have to guard
your heart
even more when you're not in your home
when you're not in your family when
you're not
in a place where you are accountable for
your actions um
and so in scripture there are places
there even in stories there are even
some stories where
there's a suggestion when you're in the
land of the foreigner you actually
act you can act upside down you're
because you're not accountable you can
steal you can take you can there's all
these stories
of jack and the beanstalk for example of
uh you know
there are many stories of characters who
when they're in the land of the
foreigner
they're somehow acceptable to steal but
here we see
in a way the christian narrative very
very strong christian narrative
which is that even in the land of the
foreign even in the land where you're
not accountable
you need to be honorable and you see
that in the very
gesture of sir gawain going out into the
foreign land to receive a blow
from this monster because of a promise
that he had made
he's willing to go out and accept the
consequences of his actions now this is
really a a story of virtue and a story
of honor
but there's also a little secret there's
also a
i don't know how to say a secret or
rather there's a mystery in the story
because he also even
through guarding his virtue he realizes
or there's an aspect that he has to take
from the foreign world
in order to be able to fight the foreign
world and i've talked about this
with you guys on as in order in
different guises
through the notion of the inversion
festival through the idea of the gagora
through the idea of the garments of skin
the vaccine all of these
images of of using death against death
or conquering death against
death in order to
defend himself from the green knight he
actually ends up compromising himself
just a little bit
he accepts a little bit of that
strange world and it appears to him as
a mirror of the situation which is first
of all it's a garter
it's a belt so it's like a margin it's
something that goes around him
but it's also green which is it's
something of the green knight
he should have been he should have been
wise enough to understand that there was
something going on when he
when the garter was green and here he is
going to wear this green
garter in order to fight off the green
knight you know it's an apotropaic
use and he's using something of the
feminine as well
he's using something of the feminine
something of
of death that is a weird a little
let's say plunging into death somehow
and
he's going to then use that against
against
death against his moment against the
green knight
but it is also in some way a
compromise that he's making you know and
so like i said
it's important to understand that often
they're aspects of these tales which
aren't
just moral they're really higher than
just morality they're
they're really showing us the kind of
pattern of reality and so you could see
for example like if you gave christ as
an example of that would be that
christ in seeing that pattern and seeing
that he had to take on
some aspects of death in order to let's
say
face death he decided to take it all on
while remaining innocent to take up all
of the
all of this drink all of the salt water
drink all of the chaos
put pretty bring it all on to him uh in
a way
that transformed everything and so that
would be like
let's say the ultimate christian version
of what is happening in this thing
whereas here it's actually a weakness he
actually compromises he actually
falls and so in this fall he
he has he has the taint of the fall on
him
you know but it's still nonetheless
through that fall and through this
little compromise
that he will be able to defeat the green
knight
but in a way it remains how can i say
this
it he ends up being shown that this was
not necessary
i've said i've talked about this before
as well which is that
um what is the story that i mentioned
mentioned about this before i
in the my video on prince ivan and and
the wolf
i talk about this where it is that
because prince yvonne compromises and
he he because he always takes the golden
girdle and he takes the in that story he
also takes like a golden girdle but it's
a it's not for
not around a woman but it's a around a
horse he takes also
uh the cage the golden cage he's still
gonna get to his goal but he's gonna
suffer
be you know going through his goal and
so here if he hadn't compromised and
taken the girdle
he would have succeeded completely the
the knight would not have even nicked
him
but even the so he compromised
compromises he falls but even through
the fall
he's going to get through the end
nonetheless
he's just going to suffer doing it it's
going to be a longer process
and a more painful process think about
it and think about it in catholic terms
in terms of like going through purgatory
like he had to go through purgatory
you know it worked he got that he got to
heaven or whatever but he had to go
through purgatory and so this is what's
happening in this
this place and so he writes the green
knight and then he has to have some
temporal punishment he has to have some
mark on him
that will signify that he that he wasn't
completely successful
um but what's interesting about it is
how the garter then becomes a marker of
his
glory nonetheless because he puts it on
his arm and for him
it's a mark of shame and he wears it as
a mark of shame
but it ends up in the vision of
everybody else
being a marker of his glory and
you can understand this it seems like
this was also related
this idea of transforming shame into
glory or
you know transforming death into glory
once again is related
this story he seems to be related to the
order of the garter in terms of
the uh it seems to have been written at
the same time as the foundation of the
order of the garter for those who don't
know what the order of the garter is it
is an
order in england uh the the highest
chivalrous order in england the order of
knights in england
and the symbolism of this order is a
garter it's a belt
and the legend about how the order of
the garter was founded was that king
henry iii
uh he was dancing with his niece who was
young and beautiful
and uh while they were dancing she
she dropped her garter like her garter
fell to the ground
and it was a moment of shame in many
ways it was a moment of shame for her to
to drop her garter right it was a moment
of shame for both of them
because there was something suggestive
about the situation
people might have thought that it was
suggesting some improper
relationship between both of them and so
instead of trying to hide it instead of
trying to pretend it didn't happen
king henry took the garter and put it up
and i think he puts it on his head or
puts around his neck or he puts on a
disorder or something
and brings it up and kind of brings it
up above and then
says loudly to everybody to hear uh
aniswaki mari ponce that is shame to
those who think
ill of what is happening shame to those
who
think evil of what is going on and so he
takes the moment of shame and
flips it in order to shame the others
and then the order of the
the garter itself becomes an image of
the night's glory
and so it then if you look at people who
are in the order of the garter
today they wear the garter as a kind of
metal it's like a kind of
uh it's a kind of image of their glory
and it also seems to be related because
the the um
the patron of the order of the garter is
saint george and so
there it also seems to be related to the
garter by which
uh saint george tamed the dragon in
certain versions of the story
because i told you before there are some
versions of the story where saint george
kills the dragon
but there are some versions of the story
in which saint uh
george tames the dragon and this
seems to be related to that once again
using death against death
once again you know using a certain
aspect of our passion
against our passions and ultimately you
could say
it's also in a way the image of gawain
who
was able to to also tame his dragon that
is
through the situation with the wife of
the the noble
he was in a situation where it was
actually more dangerous for him to
resist the lady you know he could have
given in
and then just left the castle nobody
would have known whereas
now he was more in danger by resisting
her because she could have accused him
and so he ended up nonetheless taming
his
passion and by accepting the guarder
he's also protecting himself against her
because it's a way to say okay i'm going
to give in i give in to these little
things
that that you're proposing be so that i
don't give in to the bigger thing
and actually end up sinning and so all
of this is going on in the story
it's obviously i'm just kind of skimming
the surface it's a very very powerful
and very deep story but i hope that this
these little tidbits have given you
some insight into the story and uh and
yeah so i hope you've enjoyed it
and i'm really enjoying going into these
stories i'm probably going to go into
more
for my future patron only video and once
again i want to thank you
for your support and you know it's
really i'm really happy i'm really
excited
to continue doing all of what i'm doing
and as i move into my house
next month i hope hopefully the the
regularity of the videos will be more
and also this will be better than just
this white background so thanks
everybody and i'll talk to you very soon